Anie Samson et Luc Ferrandez,
bonsoir. J'avais fait entendre
deux extraits, on parle du
retour du baseball, il y a eu
cette rencontre entre la
mairesse et Stephen Bronfman. On
l'écoute.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Il n'y aura pas d'argent
public des Montréalais
et des Montréalaises
dans ce projet-là,
dans la construction d'un stade.
Ceci étant dit, c'est un projet
qu'on trouve intéressant.
On le dit depuis le début,
mais évidemment, il y a
des étapes à suivre et
la prochaine étape pour nous,
c'est que le Groupe baseball
soit... fasse une mise à jour
à la population, puisse parler
de leur projet, sion
mais également de répondre
aux questions parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup.
STEPHEN BRONFMAN,
Groupe Baseball Montréal
- Tout le monde reconnaît que
c'est un très bon projet pour
Montréal et pour le Québec pour
le Canada. So, c'est ça que...
on eston eston eston eston est a
tous la même vision.
Il faut travailler ensemble,
c'est un jeu d'équipe avec
tous les partenaires,
même aux États-Unis ûr
que ça va fonctionner.
Et ce n'est pas juste
un stade de base-ball.
Ça, c'est un centre
communautaire pour Montréal,
ça va être actionné 12 mois
par année, ça va être
quelque chose deque,que,que,que,
on manque ça à Montréal.
Ça va juste donner plus à notre
ville qu'on aime tellement.
- Il dit que ce n'est pas
qu'un stade de baseball que ça
va être magnifique, bon, êtes-
vous convaincu et avez-vou
de voir le projet?
- La première des choses qu'on
il faut qu'on voit le projet, on
a beau dire que c'est le fun,
mais il faudrait savoir ce que
c'est, qu'est-ce que ça
implique, et dan des des des des
priorités, lorsqu'on prend des
décisions, est-ce que c'est
important, est-ce que c'est
nécessaire ou...
actuellement, c'est plus le fun
de l'avoir, quelles seront les
impacts Montréal mais surtout
les retombées. Et tant qu'on
n'aura pas toutes ces
informations, c'est pas encore
concre
- On comprend que la mairesse ne
peut pas fermer la porte à un
projet de développement
important pour Montréal.
- Exactement, et c'est un peu
dans le coin en descendant les
escaliers de la mairie avec M.
Bronfman. Mais si la population
refuse projet, quand elle dit
va voir ce que la
population a emporté en
tation publique, elle ne
veut pas avoir l'eau de dire non
elle-même, mais elle va bien
s'apercevoir que pour la
population de Pointe-Saint-
Charles, notamment, et pour une
grande proportion des
Montréalais, ils ne veulent pasn
stade baseball au centre-ville.
Il va y avoir une réaction
forte. Va s'appuyer là-dessus
pour dire non.- Je vous pousse,e
projet ne pourrait pas être
extraordinaire pour tout lmondet
pas... le problème vous allait
me dire, c'est qu'on ne les sait
pas encore.- Il est un peu trope
dire, mais c'est une question,
une position extrêmement
intéressant, Montréal n'est pas
un village, Montréal est la
métropole, c'e
Québec. Donc les métropoles ont
des grands projets mais il faut
que ces projet s..........
C'est plus sur cette partie
qu'on doit vraiment pousser,
voir ce que les montréalais vont
gagner de ça, oui, peut-être des
investne
mettra pas d'argent mais autour
de que l'on pourra négocier des
logements communautaires, plein
de choses, mais c'est là qu'on
est rendu, qu'est-ce qu'on peut
avoir de ça, qu'est-ce que les
Montréalais vont gagner de cela,
parce que c'est un gros projet,
si l'argent ne vient pas de
Montréalais, on
peut bénéficier des retombées
économiques parce qu'il va y
avoir des taxes, des emplois,
mais pour ça, il faut aller plus
loin.
- Il va y avoir un lieu animé
tout ça, c'est que encore une
fois le projet...
- ça dépend ce qu'on met là-
dedans. Quand il dit qu'il va
être animé 12 mois par année,
est-ce que par exemple qu'il
pourrait y avoir un calendrier
de spectacles rate 40 jours par
année ou des choses comme ça.
Très intéressant pour la scène
culturelle, peut-être, moins
intéressant pour les concude M.e
cet intérêt étend intéressant
pour le quartier autour,quand ot
mettre, il y a des choses qui ne
peuvent pas être mises ensemble.
Si par exemple il y avait 70
spectacles de roque à cet
endroit par anné
pas aller dans un quartier
résidentiel. Donc il faut
attendre de voir ce qu'il va y
avoir dedans.
- Attendu que l'on n'a pas le
choix d'attendre qu'il n'y a pas
de maquette, pas de projet, la
demie équipe, c'est pas clair
avec un pavé, je
parler, Montréal est une ville
universitaire, les universités
sont importantes dans l'ADN de
Montréal, l'histoire de la
professeure, elle avait prononcé
le mot en N dans sa classe de
l'Université d'Ottawa, grosse
consciente controverse, elle
avait été suspendue. Il n'y
avait pas de processus, elle
s'est ucun
autre forme de procès, il y a
des universités qui distillent
attention aux agressions,
or aujourd'hui, Alexandre
Cloutier, qui accouche de
rapport avec d'autres gens, on
va écouter deux extraits de M.
Cloutier et on revient.
ALEXANDRE CLOUTIER, président,
comité sur la li
- Je veux dire, c'est monnaie
courante que les universités
sont régies par le gouvernement
du Québec. Nous, on pense que
sur un enjeux aussi fondamental
que la mission de l'université,
ses co
l'autonomie universitaire,
la liberté universitaire.
Honnêtement, Monsieur Roy,
à notre avis, si le gouvernement
ne fait rien, la censure risque
malheureusement de s'amplifier
la situation, elle est déjà
à nos yeux à nous comme étant
relativement problématique.Une t
pas exempt d'émotion, ce n'est
pas exempt de réactions, ça ne
veut pas dire po
qu'il n'y a pas des élèves qui
peuvent se sentir heurtés, qu'il
y a des gens en raison de leurs
vécus qui ne peuvent pas vivre
des moments difficiles. On dit
aussi que les universités
doivent adopter une politique
sur la liberté universitaire est
bien identifier les retours
d'accompagnement pour les
besoins ponctuels que peuvent
vivre certains élèves.
dit en
deux mots, il dit qu'il a été
étonné de voir le nombre
d'enseignants de professeurs qui
lui ont dit qu'il se sentait
pris dans une espèce de censure,
qui marchait sur des oeufs. Il
dit que ça prend une loi pour
encadrer cela, pour donner un
espace de liberté dans les
salles de cours, ça ne veut pas
dire insulter les gens pour
insulter les gens, mais de
pouvoir discuter.
- Je trouve que son rapport est
extrêmement sévère, université
aura aucune marge de manoeuvre
après avoir appliqué les
différentes recommandations. Il
est très clair. Université
d'abord la classe n'est pas un
espace sécuritaire, l'étudiant
doit s'attendre à ce qu'il y a
des discussions qui ne lui font
pas plaisir. L'trauma
avertissement, la possibilité
qu'un professeur nomme un mot
une une problématique qui
surprenne l'élève que c'est à la
discrétion du professeur.,
Université et objet de défendre
la le professeur ou la personne
si elle est prise dans un débat
admettant avec les étudiants.
Finalement université et objet
d'encadrer les médias sociaux
dans la mesure du possible lors
des crises qui sont liées à ces
débats. Je ne dis pas qu'il va
trop loin, je dis qu'il est allé
aussi loin qu'il pouvait aller
pour encadrer l'université.
- Je trouve que son rapport
touche pas mal à toute la
problématique parce que ce n'est
pas juste avec Mme Lieutenant-
Duval, mais aussi à McGill,
Icare et Concordia où il y a eu
différentes problématiques. Je
pense que la liberté et
l'autonomie universitaire est
important, et cette loi qui sera
régie l'ensemble des université
va au moins l'encadrer et
ensuite, chaque université met
en place un comité qui pourra
voir s'il y a des litiges, il
pourra décider. Mais je crois
que c'est important, on est
rendu là. Dans le rapport, 60 %
des professeurs se sont auto
censurés pour ne pas déranger
les jeunes, mais si c'est un
lieu où un peu discuté à
l'université, c'est bien là,
c'est là qu'on se fait des
idées, qu'on fait des débats, on
apprend à échanger, mais si on
ne peut plus le faire que ça
sert à quoi. Aussi, dans cette
loi, je ne pense pas qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde ou de jeunes
qui vont être contents, parce
que 80 % de ceux qui ont répondu
au sondage, il y a eu quand
même... 80 % de ces jeunes se
sont dit que pour, il n'y a
aucun problème dans ce qui se
passe.
- En même temps, le recteur de
l'université de Montréal a dit
qu'on n'a pas besoin de l'État
pour gérer ça chez nous.
- Effectivement, ce n'est pas
tous les universités qui ont
besoin de l'État, mais quelques
universités ont fait preuve de
manque de jugement qui fait que
toutes les universités vont être
prises dans un carcan. C'est
dommage.
- C'est une recommandation qu'il
y a une loi, on verra si l